[Music]
this is about me wanting to live without
you whining in my ear all the time about
eating bad guys or like nagging me about
anne or destroying my place or
destroying my life do you know how lucky
you are i chose you you chose me
buddy i'm the only person that took you
in when your friends kicked you off the
planet mingmon cause you are a reject
you are a pariah lethal protection my
ass you couldn't protect anything you
are useless you can get a job down here
cleaning toilets
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it again
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free you have got to get
control of your aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it
again
[Music]
i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
this carnage
i promise
betty
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
[Music]
you